al any chance this was an accident last
night Mike my gut here I'll paint the
picture for you you got it you got a
very good player in a corner he's
wearing you now he's got whatever three
home runs leading it to the to that game
you go through your scouting report and
somewhere along the line it's like guys
you've got to make him feel
uncomfortable move his feet the usual
jargon that is obvious that here's a guy
that's feeling very comfortable that's
that I can't explain it any more than
that Dan the whole premise of pitching
is to make batters not comfortable which
means to offset their timing and their
balance and that's why you throw a 95 on
our fast balls and you come back with a
76 - curveball and then you throw one
upstairs and then you throw a slider in
the dirt that's the premise of hitting
and pitching and that's baseball so I
don't think Jose Aranea it has the
ability or command to be able to
precisely throw a ball really wants to
do so the optics are awful you throw the
first pitch of the game which is
terrible and you hit a guy that has been
doing really well against you it only
gets you but in league so it looks awful
I'm just speaking out loud as to what
possibly could have gone in pitchers
meeting prior to going into your first
pitch or going and pitch in the game
there's Scout reports go in go out he
likes it down he likes it up hey stay
away from this he can't hit the breaking
ball whatever whatever perhaps and I'm
only saying perhaps because obviously we
weren't in the room that hey listen just
just make him feel uncomfortable move
his feet you know knock them down move
them back so that's where I'm not sure
it you know obviously we're not sure
unless we know exactly what's in the
mind of the pitcher which every picture
never admits to it anyway so was that a
was that a bad answer no I but I'm not
trying to understand it from a pitchers
perspective here because let's say you
hit him accidentally is there a way to
say I'm sorry or my bad or got away from
me because if you look at urania 'he's
reaction he's sort of he's waiting for
somebody to come out to the mound he
throws his glove down
so it doesn't look like he's contrite
apologetic it feels like there was a
little bit more combative attitude yeah
I I agree with that and that's why I
think you know the assumption is what
everybody felt and it's a it's it's an
intense game right I mean you have a you
have a five and a half ounce baseball
that's thrown 97 miles an hour and it
can actually really hurt people so
that's where I think this level of you
know everybody being angry about it on
both sides yeah it didn't look good damn
it didn't look good here's a guy in his
last I just quickly you know his last
seven starts he's doing 30 innings he's
walked 14 batters almost it's almost
five four nine five every every game
right four plus so you know he doesn't
have command he's hit what - that was
his 12th batter 129 innings I'm not
making an excuse for the kid it looks
awful it shouldn't have been done I
wasn't the best guy to be able to throw
a ton of strikes but I had the ability
to command pitch and I do kind of
general area where I'm going and the
optics say awful awful awful I never
ever did I hit a guy in the big leagues
because he was wearing me out or it
sorts or my team the only time that I
was at it was ever directed was usually
a manager because I was protecting my
players and usually meant either if
somebody came in hard at home or at
second base to break up a double play or
if one of my guys were getting worn out
throwing the series you know you get the
directive and it's it's very simple a
lot of times you know veteran pitchers
understand and know what they have to do
to defend their players because the last
thing you want in your Clubhouse our
players thinking that the pitchers don't
protect you yeah I guess trying to
understand this and also does this
continue now if you were pitching
tonight for the Braves and you're facing
the Marlins would you have to be told
anything what would happen in the first
inning
oh yeah I'm picking you know I don't
know pick your guy in the lineup and it
would be first inning so long as it
weren't already borings I think Donnie
knows I think Tim Wallick knows I think
one the other snows the pick the coaches
set for their pack and all those guys
was a veteran guys been around a long
time there's not going to be like say
what are they doing there will be an if
there's a warning history you don't want
your pitchers get thrown out because of
it but if there's not I think there
needs to be some
because it looked very obvious wait
you're going to got the warning you know
that the umpires gonna say to you
pregame hey al if you're going inside
early I'm gonna run you okay well then
now that changes it because I don't want
to get thrown out a game in the first
inning I would probably pick my spot
later in the game to make it seem not so
obvious but somewhere along the line
your your guys have to know Dan that you
can't be pinned cushions for opposing
opposing teams that was whole Tony
LaRussa thing get one of mine I get two
of yours
you hit my three hitter I hit your three
hitter so you know that was absolutely
listen you said that long you know we
know the stories of Don Drysdale and Bob
Gibson and you know guys just dug in
they would apologize to Bob Gibson and
say sorry mr. Gibson I was just trying
to get a better footing he'd knock you
down we're no longer you know 67 he's
baseball but you know yeah something
something needs to be done just to say
hey you can't you can't get away with
that and once again I'm watching the
video I didn't you just put your hand up
to say my bad and and it feels like it
diffuses it a little bit and that's why
I think there was more to it he's thrown
97 he's not even close to the plate and
look at the reaction of the catcher to
because there's a surprise element in
addition to what you just said I agree
because I looked at the video and then
the replays but watch the reaction you
know it you know normally there's a
catcher like he you know he kind of you
know kind of shied away from it he jumps
you know is that real motel I should
know that you know it's just kind of
here comes the pitch and you know if you
look at it he just kind of you know
there was very little reactions to him
as well I don't know yeah it's the
optics are not good you're if you're in
the Borland I'm talking to a lighter
former Major League Baseball pitcher and
analyst for a major league baseball
Network and I didn't understand this
either out let's say somebody hits 2
home runs off of you
the next guy who comes up who hasn't
done anything to you gets dusted or you
might hit him so explain that one to me
through the lens of a pitcher all right
so I've never done that I always felt
like I'm you know I just either not
good enough or I just would make it bad
pitches the explanation is is that you
have personalities and people and and
and and humans that are that have
emotions and it's not justified i i
completely I've never done that but you
have a guy in the mound he's pissed I
mean there's no other way saying it and
what's the way to to event it you yeah
I'm gonna hit this guy I'm gonna you
know I'm not throwing a guy not not
right
it's wrong but listen you're I'm on the
mound
I feel like I'm get worn out I can't get
you out I'm bad and I'm gonna come
inside
yeah yeah it's it's it's kind of a big
baby actually yeah but a hitters not
allowed to do anything let's say you're
striking out you know 12 14 guys it's
not like a hitter can go you know what
I'm gonna make you uncomfortable on the
mound I'm gonna go out there with my dad
you can't do it right whose eleska I did
that no we've got to go back to Burt
campaneris but was it somebody recently
right so threw a bat does Machado
somebody threw a bat I forget one right
so I've seen that you know where you
know listen I it's hard for me because I
hate guys I came in a lot that was my mo
two right-handed batters so I don't know
whether people just just knew that that
was kind of how I threw and I came in
hard I mean I remember hit man or man oh
to pitch in the helmet the ball flew
into the stands this was at the Jake in
Cleveland I'm clearly not on purpose
I've had a lot of guys I hit to in life
on the kneecap I throw he's gonna come
out twist me like a pretzel and beat me
up
but did you ever apologize or put your
hand up to say hey my be in the moment
just the same so here I will tell you I
didn't like the body language that did
say like oh yeah ya know what you know
so there was a little tough guy element
which there's a whole Roboto much
reasonable thing to this anyway yeah I
would I would I
it's a fine line then because you don't
want to do like what the literally kid
did you know I thought it was cute as
heck but you know a kid hits a home run
high fives them as he's known around
spaces like that you know somewhere
between that and you know Aranea you
know you don't want you kind of want to
show hey man I'm bad I'm sorry most of
the time it's futile because the meter
yes he's mad and he got hit every hitter
thinks every pitcher has unbelievable
command and and impeccable control so
every time they get hit they think most
of the guys think it's on purpose which
is not so they're mad so what do you
know you're gonna wave at him say my bad
sorry there's a there's a middle line
there of you can look like you're upset
without going overboard with you know
and then also without making it look
like I did on purpose were you on the
match staff when Piazza got hit with
Clemens yeah are you kidding
yeah so let's see that was that was game
well no no it was during the Subway
Series in the Yankee Stadium I I don't
know who was pitched in that game and
then the very good Shawn Estes pitching
man because yes thank you it was really
unfair Sean came to the Mets like a
couple years later it really wasn't his
fight I really wish I was on the mound
or I think Rick Reed was still there
somebody who was actually in the
building during the World Series that
needed to hit Roger Roger knew who's
gonna get hit and here's Sean you know
the first year from San Francisco and
you know he threw one behind him or
whatever I didn't he didn't hit him and
it really yeah no no Roger needed to get
hit that was a hundred percent
retaliation to our best player Mike
Piazza you don't do that and he got hit
and Mike's convinced a hundred percent
that that was on purpose not to be hit
in the head because of Michael is
wearing him out Mike had really good
numbers against Roger any other baseball
story lines you want to touch on well I
have you how about them Red Sox yeah
he's got to get going here
dad I got the I have a Marlins Yankee
series with with Michael K and Paul
O'Neill coming up next week in Miami so
this would be this would be good good
conversation with Paul O'Neill also the
Dodgers without Kenley Jansen I mean I
know they got they won last night but
man they falling apart here with that
bull pen I know but I mean I like
Arizona Colorado is right there with LA
I mean what it is
start with division I mean in the sense
of really who's taken off
who's the one Arizona's done a nice job
where they ten eleven games over five
hundred but you just look at the east of
what the Red Sox are doing and you know
even Cleveland in Houston American
League just it's just so clear and
distinct we both the Peru team we've
been talking about American League MVP
it foregone conclusion somebody from the
Red Sox is gonna win JD Martinez
I feel like Mookie Betts is more
valuable I think Martinez has had better
numbers but I don't know how the voters
going to see this but it feels like it's
a two-man race here yes yes I think
without question and what JD Martinez
did I I think that gets it but I think
what Martinez first of all what a sign
right what a story in baseball a guy
gets released and he's a a division 2
player at Nova Southeastern and Houston
gets rid of him and he turns his career
around and amazing what he did for
Arizona last year and Dave Nebraska
certainly knew what he had and the talk
with JD Martinez was his swing is that
right center swing that Miguel Cabrera
kind of sit and watching him in batting
practice and you know he's proven a lot
of people wrong you know it's harder to
go to right-center you can start pulling
the ball impressive impressive year that
he's happened but I think overall I
agree with the defense of what Mookie
Betts brings in all aspects of his game
I think he probably is maybe a little
ahead I like the Jenny Martinez story I
really do and then in the National
League it feels like Scherzer is
involved in the conversation just
because we may not have that great
everyday player Carpenter's done well
Javy Baez from the Cubs I don't know if
you throw anybody else in there but here
was the one thing I wanted to ask you I
can give Scherzer decide young I have no
problem with that
but if I'm gonna include him in the MVP
race I got to hold him accountable for
his team if they don't make the playoffs
then how valuable is he if I you know
because we've done that before where
you'll say well hey he got his team into
the playoffs well if he's not in
carpenters not then it might be Javy
Baez who would be your MVP in the
National League I agree as you're saying
it
he's Eddie Freeman with you know
bleeding League and hits or average I
I'd have a tough time of that by the way
don't don't sleep on Jacob degrom I mean
it that's I know he's got what's he got
seven wins or something crazy yeah but
you know statistically I love Scherzer
III just love everything about him also
to that's been a disappointment for sure
what the Nationals have done but degrom
is going to be right there how God will
be really interesting to see what how
that plays out with a guy you know the
winds are out the window especially with
you know the voters of having a better
analytic you know sabermetric mine now
we saw that a few years ago when King
Felix won with 13 wins I just don't know
if Scherzer has kind of distinguished
himself enough as for being an MVP you
know saw young obviously and it'll
probably you know him and degrom you
know maybe it's a close race but you
know Scherzer
you got to win 24 25 games it feels like
if you're gonna have a pitcher in the
MVP race and Scherzer hasn't done that
even though you can say he's the best
pitcher in baseball
I'm I'm with and but I think what makes
it interesting and you're making a great
point if Scherzer words he has 17 wins
15 or 16 he he just lost money you know
they blew on the other night reason why
what you're justifying is that you know
who really is standing out offensively I
mean we just mentioned Baez with the
RBIs and not carpenter unbelievable is
what 33 home runs and then you know he's
throwing a Freddy Freeman and you know
there's really nobody that's glaringly
standing out so I think a guy like
Scherzer assumed and he continues with
the strikeouts and gets the wood racks
up the wins and stays there with the
Grauman er a he could be yes he could be
a BP yeah and then he would be what
three times four times I think before
that's right for he's got three doesn't
make him a hall-of-famer al I think so
so a while ago I did a show a movie
tonight there did Network and we had a
board and it was there's 10 guys that
have had three sigh yawns 7 I'm in the
Hall of Fame and the
that or not or it is Kershaw fact that
Kershaw Scherzer and Roger Clemens and
we know right of why Rogers not in so
you know that that itself says a lot
right I mean the window of your 8 to 12
year dominance you're saying your but a
starting pitcher doesn't get to 200 wins
but it would make the the Hall of Fame
is kind of interesting there I think
it's changing I mean we see that with
the with the metrics if it's a base
starting relievers because they want to
get the seventh inning guy to get the
first three batters they kidding me
there's a reason why he's in the pen
because he's not good enough to start it
drives me crazy
so Windsor yeah I mean you're not gonna
see 300 no way no way I think to 225 is
the new 300 it's good to catch up I'm
glad you're all fired
yeah I'm glad you're fired yeah but if
you threw inside I'm coming out you
coming out and then you got one punch
and I'm bringing down bigger and fatter
than you up yeah I bring in the bat with
me out you use the ball I get to use the
bat out that's the way it works
Thank You bud good to talk to you all
right that's Al Leiter MLB Network
analyst for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]